I don't endorse any of the companies
that we have the biggest risk for me is
brand I'm really betting that this guy
gal company is not going to do anything
really dumb and that's tough because
there's a lot of people in businesses if
you're ahead of marketing DM some girl
who's underage and it becomes this whole
thing and then my brand gets associated
with that I can control me if I'm going
to do it I want to have as much control
as I can and so that's why I don't
normally do it that way it's also a
little bit of a risk to the business
because if I'm a huge driver of value to
the business then it does make it more
difficult to sell because then the
acquirer would have to make a deal with
me and to deal with the company we do
this ultimately to make the companies
independently more valuable rather than
make them dependent on us which long
term robs them of the value that they
could make on their own